good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 204 object class
Keter special containment procedures SCP
204 1 and SCP 204 2 are to be kept in a
10 by 10 meter fortified holding area
inside the holding area must be
constructed out of armour plated steel
and heavily reinforced concrete the
holding area must also be vacuum sealed
and contained within an outer shell with
a higher air pressure that must always
be maintained with at least 2 psi or the
current air pressure in the holding area
at least one full security team must be
kept on standby at all times it is only
during SCP 204 one scheduled feeding
times that d-class personnel are allowed
to enter for the purposes of maintenance
SCP 204 once typical diet consists of
any kind of meat preferably from living
subjects such subjects will often
consist of aggressive animals such as
wild dogs Bulls or any other animal that
must be euthanized due to aggression
however d-class personnel will also
suffice if such food sources are
unavailable as CP 204 two's diet
consists of a regular human diet with no
special measures required SCP 204 2 is
allowed to make special requests but any
and all requests must be given o 5
approval any personnel caught attempting
to deliberately provoke SCP 204 2 will
be immediately terminated
security personnel are required to
ignore any and all of SCP 204 to s
attempts to provoke a response from them
unless there is a clear and present risk
of containment bridge failure to do so
will result in harsh administrative
punishment when SCP 204 2 is about to
turn the age of 14 the foundation must
initiate containment protocol to O for
further details may be found in
containment protocol to all four
requirements in the event of a
containment breach
EMP generators must be immediately
activated in order to keep SCP 204 1
disabled once EMP generators have been
activated security teams have
approximately 30 seconds to neutralize
SCP 204 - before SCP 204 one can adapt
and reassemble itself if containment
cannot be achieved in this time as CP
204 1 must be contained by conventional
means security teams and agents are
authorized to use any conventional
weaponry at their disposal to contain a
CP 204 1 and a CP 204 - if SCP 204 - is
terminated during containment then
containment protocol 204 must
immediately be initiated description as
CP 204 1 is a semi organic nanomachine
colony that follows SCP 204 - as a form
of protector SCP 204 one spends the
majority of its time in a dispersed
cloud where it is almost impossible to
perceive with normal human senses
however if SCP 204 - is put into danger
or if SCP 204 - commands it to SCP 204
one will instantaneously materialize
into a solids physical form the exact
shape and nature of this form is
subjective depending wholly upon SCP 204
- s view state of mind
imagination despite its variable nature
as CP 204 one has a number of common
traits
these include massive strength large
size basic intelligence perfect
obedience to SCP 204 - and the ability
to regenerate itself after consuming
living flesh SCP 204 one is vulnerable
to conventional weaponry and can be
temporarily forced back into its
dispersed state if enough damage is
inflicted as CP 204 - is always a child
ranging from 4 to 14 years old
physically there is nothing outstanding
about SCP 204 - besides its ability to
call upon a CP 204 one all incidences of
SCP 204 - have common traits all of them
have had a history of abuse and danger
with many developing acute mental
disorders as a result this makes
instances of scp-2000 to such children
though why or how it finds them is
currently unknown if SCP tool for - is
terminated or reaches the age of 14
then SCP 204 1 will abandon it and find
a new child to imprint on as a form of
self-preservation
if SCP 204 one cannot find a suitable
child it will immediately materialize
and go berserk
attacking anything in sight once SCP 204
one finds a suitable candidate to
protect it immediately imprints upon SCP
204 - and will follow until a CP 204 2
expires or a CP 204 1 decides to leave
of its own accord
at first SCP tool form one appears
benign protecting SCP 204 - from overt
threats however through careful study
and observation it has been noted that
all incidences of
CP 204 to begin to adopt much more
aggressive dangers seeking behavior with
little regard to human life it is
theorized that SCP 204 one is able to
manipulate a CP 204 twos thought
processes in order to behave in a
fashion that would benefit it it is
assumed that since SCP tool for one
requires organic flesh for sustenance
it needs SCP 204 - to be in danger in
order to justify its activation see
addendum 1 for further details
addendum 1 there have been numerous
recorded incidences where it is believed
as CP 204 one has been involved the
first such recorded incident was when a
car was found in a residential street
completely torn apart and covered and
partially devoured human remains similar
incidents occurred until agents managed
to track a CB 204 one where they made
contact with the first recorded
incarnation of SCP 204 - it took three
more attempts and numerous casualties
before SCP 204 1n SCP 204 - were
successfully contained interviews with
SCP 204 - revealed that it seemed to
feel a need to experience danger
such as standing in traffic or provoking
hostile responses from others when
questioned on its reasons SCP 204 -
simply replied that as CP 204 one
allowed it to containment protocol 204
in order to keep SCP 204 one
successfully contained it has been
necessary to keep a permanent stock of
candidates to replace SCP 204 - in the
event that the current one is terminated
or abandoned ideally all candidates
should be orphans below the age of 10
with a history of abuse however in times
of need
article 12 of containment protocol - a
form may be authorized to allow
candidates that don't meet specific
requirements it will be put under the
supervision of caretakers which will
consist of d-class personnel convicted
of violent crimes child abuse and
with foundation staff present to prevent
inadvertent termination of candidates if
SCP tool for to successfully reaches the
cutoff age of 14 years in SCP 204 one
abandons it the former SCP 204 - must
undergo a rigorous amnestic treatment
and a thorough psychological examination
before being reintegrated into a
government foster program if it is
deemed that the former SCP 204 - cannot
be successfully reintegrated then the
subject must be immediately terminated
addendum - as of the writing of this
report the foundation has contained 13
instances of scp-2121 instances
exhibited the trademark hostile and
violent behavior typical among all
instances of scp-2217
the exact mechanisms SCP 204 one uses to
manipulate its hosts is still unknown
addendums three though there is evidence
to suggest that SCP 204 one may be
sentient or possibly even sapient all
attempts to communicate directly with
SCP 204 one have resulted in failure
currently the only feasible method of
communicating with SCP 204 one is to use
SCP 204 - as an intermediate
unfortunately the violent tendencies and
hostile behavior exhibited by nearly all
instances of scp-2029 stability make
this approach highly unreliable
man some kids have really tough lives as
it is but being possessed by killer
nanomachine robots is there no justice
in this world in fact you know what I
can tell you 100% that there isn't quick
sidenote I apologize about my voice
today I think I've got some kind of hay
fever hopefully it wasn't too taxing to
listen to anyway thank you for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
good bye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert geum's
Sabah Chris all Pablo ice 917 Kareem el
ash mooing Justin day Thomas Morin Curie
kuma white crew and jayvo Jack witch
doctor crystal Roos my archive curator
Nick Joseph Lewis ooh eggy agent vamp
King modding Drakkar the wanderer and
Joshua Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you